The Joe Rogan Experience the thing about
things like whether it's SEALS or any
high level military operation group
whenever you're dealing with people that
have done something that's
extraordinarily difficult there's like a
rite of passage that you guys have gone
through that a lot of people think is
missing from particularly young men in
our society and culture there's no real
moment where you recognize that you've
you've done something incredibly
difficult and you've actually become a
man
it almost seems like Society is pushing
it the other direction where that
shouldn't exist or it should be avoided
even with the teams one of the things I
hear is this narrative that it's too
difficult
I think you got to consider the source
run that one you know like the most
recent thing that came out I'm sure you
saw this Mike was the there was a video
of training that occurred I'm pretty
sure it was on San Clemente Island
because that's where the Cs gassed us
and there's guys who are outside and
they're getting exposure to CS gas
which I remember before I joined the
military if you look at any movie
probably up to and including like full
metal jacket or if you even went into a
recruiting office exposure to CS gas is
something that you do in basic training
except to the air I don't know if the
air force does it
yeah I don't know let's assume that they
do probably they don't but let's assume
that they do
it was completely standard and normal to
see and that room sucks you go into a
room you have a gas mask on and they
make you take it off and they make you
either do something or say something or
talk so you can't hold your breath
that's the point of all that so this
video comes out
of students that are outside which one
is it actually a huge Advantage because
it dissipates quickly especially if
there's any kind of wind and they're
getting gassed and there's already
issues with the story that I'm telling
because one who the [ __ ] is filming this
like it just the fact that there was
somebody there who was filming this
thing and it made it onto the internet
in any way shape and form is a is a
mistake in and of itself so it couldn't
have been someone who's in the program
so the students the last
four weeks of training you go out to San
Clemente Island it's called third phase
and you get a very basic indoctrination
into small unit tactics
rifle Weaponry explosives you throw some
grenades um you do some underwater demo
but you're out there for like the last
tight four weeks of training the
students I mean I don't I don't even
remember having a cell phone when I went
through actually a 97
I'd be shocked if they're allowed to
have cell phones on there so it had to
have been an instructor
but they're getting gassed
they're being made to sing Happy
Birthday again so you can't hold your
breath and it looks horrible
because it is horrible and the point of
that training is is it's supposed to
suck it's supposed to be difficult
you're supposed to be exposed to that
in a controlled training environment
people like well this one person looked
like they were passing out and there's
mucus coming out of their face like yeah
it's it's CS gas it sucks but the first
time you experience that shouldn't be in
a combat zone so
it's a volunteer only program you can
leave this particular training block if
you want to at any given time and oh by
the way every branch of the military
exposes their people to this so although
there are people who are saying yeah
it's too difficult I think you have to
consider the source I don't think they
know what they're talking about we
expose people to it on Fear Factor
yeah
again voluntary and if there's officers
and if they didn't want to I bet you
they can be like you know what Mr Rogan
I'm done with this episode like I'm out
yeah so what what happened with that
particular video it made its way onto
the internet and
it because of what it looks like it
looks like exactly what it is a really
shitty Evolution where you can't breathe
your sinuses are running more than you
ever have had them run in your life you
can't see you can barely talk you're
choking you're gagging some people throw
up so it made it onto the internet and
people started saying how could you do
that like this this is too brutal of
training how could you possibly do this
that's weird that people on the internet
had opinions
so they just had opinions did you just
say it was weird the people on the
internet
clearly being sarcastic okay but the
fact that anybody paid attention those
opinions it trended for a while it
actually not only did they have opinions
it's it started getting shared right and
then it started you know the next thing
you know it's on major news outlets
and then I actually think I saw an
article saying that the Navy opened an
investigation into it they have to at
that point you have to they should open
an investigation here it is navy
launches investigation into seal tear
gas video newly surfaced video showing
Navy SEAL recruits being tear gases
adding to scrutiny adding to scrutiny
over Elite military units training
practices
but you I mean you can speak to this
please because you have to have brutal
training so you have to layer onto this
I'm going to say this yeah I remember
going through this in the Marine Corps I
cannot recall that Evolution on San
Clemente and I asked about it here
they're like oh yeah it happened I can't
I can't remember it we went we went out
into a demo range and they had sprinkled
in CS powder into the dirt so we didn't
actually realize we were having an
exposure to it and people were just
covered in I remember I'm sitting there
we were trying to do demo calculations
or like cut debt cord and you're like
dry heaving the reason I would say the
reason that this is probably the bigger
issue is that there was a high profile
death in uh Seal training not too long
ago uh with a student who had just
completed hell week and died in the
hospital shortly thereafter
um
the young man's mother is a nurse and
she's very vocal about what has happened
and there was an investigation involving
that so it seems like
um not to I mean
horrendous to lose uh your son in any
way shape or form I don't want to take
anything away from that but from that
incident you know this is like another
layer on top of the onion on something
that people were already talking about
which in you combine the two and people
it just seems like for one I wish seals
could get the [ __ ] out of the news in
general but since it starts you know
they're layering on top of each other it
can seem to be a bigger deal than it is
what did he die from
infection yes and so during hell week
you've got open source you're you're in
the water which isn't far from the
Tijuana where it drains off uh so
there's that's always been a concern and
we mitigate it extremely well and first
off my condolences to the mother because
this kid was a stud he was the captain
of the Yale football team he was going
to become a seal he passed the hardest
so is it like a staph infection it was a
staph infection
and you look at the source
bacterial pneumonia
you look at the source this is all New
York Times it's a string of reporters
say New York Times that have just been
they've had a hard on
for the SEAL Teams they have been going
out in fact they wrote a book and you
have the author Matt Cole
um code over country yeah and and
they've just for the last
half decade if not more have made it
their personal
crusade to bring out down the SEAL Teams
and the Eddie Gallagher incident did not
help but here's what I'll say when Eddie
is a friend Eddie didn't handle all
situations well but it's amazing how
Eddie can have and I think Eddie had
like eight combat deployments how he can
serve honorably and he was number one at
the Seal team his Seal Team I think for
for E6 I believe he served honorably for
19 years in the last incident he's
involved in which he was acquitted for
that defines his entire career the last
sentence of his chapter as a seal
defines all the 19 years and all the
good work that he did in defense of our
nation for those who would never even
think of serving and he was uh acquitted
um what was the charge again it was
there was it was something about a
detainee I think the charge was murder
yes
it was it was a Isis prisoner that had
been wounded in a strike and uh while
rendering Medical Aid they they uh
accused Eddie of murder
but he was acquitted
but they still don't appreciate that he
was acquitted like they still treat him
like he's guilty
some of the things I've seen in the
Press
um and I'll keep reporters out of it one
I can't remember their names but a lot
of the liberal news media uh just have
painted him as a war criminal bottom
line and in his life has been impacted
if you look even at so first off NCIS
Naval criminal investigation service the
branch in San Diego was never held held
accountable for let's just say bad
practices that they uh implemented while
trying to bring Eddie down they also had
a hard on NCIS has not always
uh your friend and they're looking to
make a name for themselves as well and
in fact I was I was investigated the day
I retired by the same crew of people
from NCIS San Diego uh only six months
previous to when the whole Eddie
Gallagher thing uh uh sort of came on
but I mean they tapped or they put a bug
into Eddie's lawyers emails so that they
could read all the documents coming into
that lawyer they they did some pretty uh
pretty lame tactics and they were never
held accountable is that is it legal to
do that no the the initial lawyer was uh
was fired relieved and they replaced him
uh rapidly but was he relieved from
military services laterally transferred
loudly transferred and that's how they
deal with it Jamie go back to that
article again I'm gonna say something
when you first pulled up uh the uh with
the first initial complaints because I
want to
scroll yeah right there
so they were talking about uh the
protocol so here let me be clear we have
absolutely zero tolerance for hazing
abuse or deviations from safety
protocols uh as Navy Seals we serve our
fellow Americans uncompromising
Integrity is our standard our character
and honor our steadfast most of all
we're expected to lead by example in all
situations so if that is like standard
operational procedure for those kind of
training
programs why why does he have to say
that
so as hazing right it's not I mean you
could could you hate somebody with tear
gas yes what I'll say is this as
somebody who was a Bud's instructor
there is an evolution sheet and Matrix
for every single thing that happens in
training to include remediating the
students when they fall short of a
standard
there are limits to how long you can
remediate them for there's limits to the
exercises that you can use there is an
oversight Matrix of who's in charge of
the evolution what's the ratio going to
be student to instructor
there is somewhere
a matrix an evolution sheet for exposure
to CS gas in buds there is absolutely no
way that those instructors are like
hey uh hey Mike you do anything tomorrow
too let's go cast these [ __ ] like
that that doesn't happen every single
day in buds is templated why that person
said that I'm not sure but as somebody
who worked in that Pipeline with that
curriculum it exists and what they need
to say is yeah there's a reason that we
do this then the reason that we do this
is so that their first exposure isn't an
environment where their life might be on
the line that would actually shut it
down because what that does is it leaves
the door and it leaves question in
people's minds did they did they make a
mistake were they hazing people do we
need to do this my resounding answer is
yes and also I'll add to that
my answer when people ask me about
students who have died in Buds and I
think there have been ten in the history
of Bud since the 50s is that it needs to
continue to happen I don't want it to
happen I don't want anybody to lose
their life but if the training becomes
so exceedingly safe
that that's not a potential then we're
not serving people in that training and
we're not preparing them for what the
battlefield is going to expect I'll push
against you on that one if you explain
it to the American public
more than half still won't understand
they will still view it as brutal as as
unnecessary
but
you know there's been
a push to make the military
a playground for Progressive policies
and it is the last place politically
that we want people playing
and I mean you even see China has a as
an initiative to actually make their men
more masculine yeah so we're going the
opposite uh opposite direction you know
there is a diversity Equity equity and
inclusion Chief at the Pentagon now who
wrote a book that basically called The
First Responders uh menaces
and uh you know basically painted them
as as white supremacists and um
it's going a very bad Direction I will
say this about the military what people
don't understand is it is highly
professional I've always been impressed
there are standards there's Doctrine and
instructors know that they follow that
Playbook they mitigate risk to the
lowest level because you always have the
risk of getting investigated for
something like this so who's letting
these Progressive policies infect the
military how how is that ever an option
is that just people who are blissfully
unaware because they're on the outside
like how is that how does that ever get
in to the point where you're considering
things like Elite groups like The Seals
having to deal with this sort of
politically correct nonsense
personally I think the the policy of
transparency that was made or
popularized by President Obama and this
isn't I'm not attacking President Obama
he was aggressive on the war on terror
he made a lot of aggressive uh decisions
but
there are certain communities where
transparency like the CIA Special
Operations is not the best policy is
they should remain in the shadows and
there should be uh just public trust
that we are doing the right things we
don't want anyone to pass away in
training we we don't want to get anyone
hurt but we also don't want to advertise
our capabilities or our training or our
capacities to potential uh military
peers like China or Russia so the
transparency for me propaganda do it
with a regular military keep keep
Special Operations even doing it with
the regular military like why
I don't have an answer for how it it
started infiltrating other than it seems
to be the Groundswell I mean the
military is just a is just a group of
people from normal societies so I don't
think it's uncommon to see things that
our society is dealing with working
their way into the military but I do
hope that there is a backstop against it
and in my mind it everything needs to be
worked in a reverse Direction what is it
we're asking these people to do in the
real world execution of their job
now let's work our training pipeline to
prepare those people for that